(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners...
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We think we can take our sales
to $3 million.
Whoa.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
I built a hundred-million-dollar
business in record time.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
She's out of her mind.
I don't know
where he comes from,
thinking that he knows
all about the retail world...
you can go
to a mass market with $90,000?
Because he's not even in it.
You're crazy.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
You didn't ask
for enough money!
That's the problem!
That's it! I knew it.
It's sink...
Shucky ducky quack quack.
Be nice.
Or swim.
You have sharks
fighting for you.
How is your order
better than Robert's?
It's always better
when you have me.
♪♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
are Brooke Bryant
and Brittany hayes,
who are hoping
to elevate the decor
of children's bedrooms.
Hey, y'all.
We are
the Georgia peaches
behind the next
multimillion-dollar
children's decor company,
Addison's Wonderland.
My name is Brittany Hayes.
And my name is Brooke Bryant.
We are seeking an investment
of $90,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company.
Addison's Wonderland
is the most unique,
versatile, and exquisite
line of children's bedding
on the market today--
So much so
that when moms see it,
they will never want
to buy ordinary again.
When my sweet little Addison
was ready for her first bed,
I started my search
for her big-girl room.
And everything I found
had such Bland colors,
lacked detail,
and most of the selection
just was so plain,
it looked kind of cheap.
So I got out my sketchbook
and started working
on my vision
of the ultimate
little girl's room.
I got to work creating pillows,
window treatments, and bedding.
Addison absolutely
loved her room,
and so did everyone
who saw it.
Brittany and I have been friends
for a really long time,
and I've always believed in her
amazing creativity and design.
So when she asked me
to partner with her,
I didn't think twice.
We are ready
to make Addison's Wonderland
into a brand name
that everyone
will want to have
for their child.
So which of you
wants to team up
with these motivated,
hardworking Southern gals
and become the next
designer home decor empire?
Ladies, no shark is
as fashion-forward as I am.
(laughter)
So is this sold
through retailers,
or are you selling this
all direct online?
Right now we are selling it
direct online.
And you offer it
as a whole piece?
On our web site,
we have what's called
"Build your collection,"
where you can go through,
and it easily kind of
navigates you through.
If you wanna buy
the Addison collection,
you know, you click
the duvet, pillows...
Oh, I see.
And it'll kind of
show you.
Or you can go
to each individual--
like, the pillow section,
and order pillows.
And what would this cost?
A whole bedding set
runs about $1,400
for a twin set.
That's $1,400?
Are you hand-sewing this
yourself at home?
We have a small
custom workroom
that does all
of our work locally,
but that's one of
the reasons we're here,
is to get better
manufacturing options.
Yeah.
'cause that's very expensive
for a child's...
that's another reason.
Bed.
We would like to get
the price point down
to a more reasonable rate.
How long have you
been selling this again?
Exactly a year.
How's it been going?
Good.
We've sold $130,000 so far.
Wow.
And what's your cost
on that $130,000?
Our gross margin right now
is about 55%.
And, Brittany,
what's the average order size?
The average order size has been
between $800 and $1,200.
Whoa.
(Lori) Whoa.
How are people
finding your web site?
We are just--Right now
mainly on social media.
I posted some sneak peeks,
and it just took off.
I mean, we got
hundreds of comments.
And people were like,
"what date
and what time
is this coming out?"
mm-hmm.
That just seems
like so much money to me.
It does to me, too.
So this is a very,
very high-End...
Yes.
Exclusive product line?
Yes. We would like
to get it down
to a little bit less
of a high-End.
If--if that's the market
you're catering to,
and it seems to be
accepting that price point,
why bring the price down?
The feedback we've gotten
is if it were
about 30% lower in price,
we could reach a broader market.
We're kind of--
Isn't the online strategy
a way to keep this
so that you can fulfill
for everybody that wants it?
I mean, maybe this isn't
destined to be a huge business.
Maybe it's meant
to be a profitable one...
right.
Where you just charge people
outrageous prices
for this stuff.
They won't survive that way.
No, that's not true at all.
That's not True at all, Lori.
Kevin, shockingly enough,
is--is right.
Um, you guys
are identifying a niche.
Thousands of people
come to your site.
You're selling to them.
I don't agree with Mark.
I have always based my model
off of making
great quality product
at a great, affordable price
so that it can be enjoyed
by the masses.
The good news is, your model
is not the only model.
And... Wait...
there's lots of other ways
to make money.
Wait, wait, wait.
Mark, I was talking.
Excuse me.
I think that for you
to make a good profit,
you're going to need
to hit the masses.
That's really
the way to go.
You can't--
Mark, there's a recession
going on.
Most people--
They're struggling to just...
$1,400 for a mortgage payment.
Well, I think--
we haven't done any--
and they're saying
they wanna get their price down.
She's out of her mind.
You're asking for $90,000.
I don't know
where he comes from
thinking that he knows
all about the retail world...
you can go into
a mass market with $90,000?
Because he's not even in it.
You're crazy.
Well, I think we would like to
go a little bit more wholesale.
Like, we have
a lot of boutiques
want to put it
in their storefront.
Any specialty chains?
Bellini is one of them.
I remember buying, uh, a crib
for my daughter in Bellini's.
I think I'm just
paying it off now,
and she's almost 18.
(laughs)
Another reason we'd like
to get our cost down
is so that we can
offer a wholesale rate.
But that's a completely
different business
than what you're in now.
You've got end users
willing to pay crazy prices
for colorful sheets
and pillows.
Now you want to start servicing
a distribution business
that wants at least
a 50% margin.
Yeah, you may be trying
to grow too BIG too fast.
You have a good business here.
Yeah. I mean, that's what
we're trying to avoid.
And that's why we're here,
to need your advice.
'cause we feel like...
are you sure you're ready
to bring in
a... a third voice?
Yes.
Definitely.
Just a little background
on me...
okay.
So you know I'm not just,
like, a sew-at-Home mom--
when I was in college,
my husband and I
got married at 20,
and he decided he wanted
to start a granite company.
So I went in with him,
we worked our...
booties off,
and by the time
we were 23,
we graduated from college,
and the company was selling
$2 1/4 million.
I know business.
I really do.
(Daymond) All right.
We may be sweet
Southern girls, but...
Yeah, we can work hard.
We're hard workers...
yes.
And we're motivated
and passionate.
What happened
to that business, Brittany?
It's still in business.
I-I... you know, I think--
I think you're on
the right track.
Your first year in,
you've done $130,000 in sales,
and you're profitable.
You know, in some ways,
you have the perfect business.
Not sure I agree
with the strategy
of going away from that.
Not a market I understand.
I'm out.
I will say I-I love
your creativity,
and I think
that you will go far.
But I'm more
interested in products
that, uh, can be affordable
by most of the population,
as opposed to just a few.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
I really don't think
you need us.
I think this is a business
that you could run
out of your home,
you can make
a couple hundred thousand,
maybe even a million,
and you can grow
the business like that.
I wouldn't be of any assistance
to you. I'm out.
Here's what
Mr. Wonderful says--
There's nothing unique
or proprietary about it.
You're wonderful Southern girls.
I get all that.
But frankly,
if I wasn't so wonderful,
and I wanted
to knock this off,
I could do it
for a lot less.
This is the brutal reality
of business.
So I'm out.
Mark? (chuckles)
(chuckles)
As someone who's going through,
right now,
redoing the rooms
for a 6-year-old
and a 9-year-old daughter,
I'm getting brutalized
with all this stuff, right?
And so my wife would love it.
And I recognize
that it's relatively expensive,
but there's a market there
as well.
But a lot of investors,
when they look at an investment,
they look at R.O.I.--
return on investment.
I look at R.O.T., you know?
Return on my time.
What are you gonna do, Mark?
You know your daughters
would love this.
Yes, they would love it.
(laughs)
You're gonna kill me.
Um...
I love the way these ladies
are pulling your heartstrings.
(women laugh)
Just think--You could design
your daughter's room,
on your own.
Go online...
yes. You could do this.
I'm thinking.
You're fine.
Take your time.
Evaluating.
I mean, I like
what you guys are doing.
If you were
half a million in sales
or a million in sales,
then, you know,
then we could say, "Okay,
this is gonna result
in me making
"X" Amount of dollars.
It's just gotta
be worth my time.
And I think
you guys don't need me.
I think we do, though.
We--we do.
Our sales have doubled
in the last six months.
I think you guys
are gonna do wonderful things.
I think you don't
have to rush it.
I'm-a say I'm out.
No.
Shocking, but true.
Yeah, I didn't
see that coming.
Thank y'all so much
for your time...
Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
And encouragement.
(Lori) Good luck with everything.
You guys
will do very, very well.
And if you need help
with your daughter's room...
yes, call us.
I would be more than happy.
Trust me, I'm taking notes,
and I'm gonna give it
to my wife.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right. Thank y'all.
Thank y'all.
Good luck.
(Robert)
Who can afford $1,400?
(Kevin) Apparently,
many people.
At least $130,000
worth of people so far.
Look, there's nothing wrong
with what they're doing,
but that's never
gonna get big.
It's crazy.
They'll be fine.
Having the five sharks say
that we didn't need them
was a little bit
of a disappointment.
We definitely
wanted a deal.
But it was actually
a great boost of confidence,
'cause we know
that we can do it without them.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
is Steve Maloney,
with a game-changing
innovation for duck hunters.
(duck call quacking)
(laughs)
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Steve Maloney,
president of Muddy Water Camo.
And today,
we are seeking $150,000
for a 5% equity
in our business.
Sharks, we have created a new
process of making camouflage
that's going to revolutionize
the hunting industry.
The whole purpose of camouflage
is to help the person wearing it
blend into the environment.
Now Bubba over here
is wearing a sample
of where camo started.
Does that look like
the real outdoors to you?
No.
Of course not.
As an obsessed duck hunter,
I kept asking,
"where's the camo that looks
like the places where I hunt?"
after 30 years
of searching for camo
that actually looked like
a real marsh,
I finally decided I'm just
gonna have to make it myself.
(duck call quacking)
(laughter)
That's when he called me.
Hee-Haw!
(Lori laughs)
I'm Stephen Kirkpatrick.
I've been a professional
wildlife photographer
for over 30 years now.
My profession demands
that I stay hidden.
So I've been searching
for more realistic camo myself.
So together, we set out
to create one.
And now, five years later,
it's finally here.
Introducing Muddy Water Camo.
Here's me in muddy water.
Where?
(Lori) Yeah.
I'm-a have to help you out
here a little bit.
Here I am...
and here's Stephen.
(Lori) Wow.
(Mark) Where'd you go, Waldo?
(Stephen) Muddy water
is photographic camo.
It is created outdoors,
where hunting happens,
as opposed to indoors,
on some kind of computer screen.
The entire pattern
is 100% in focus,
and therefore 100% realistic,
just as nature appears
to a bird's eye.
We have found the way
to make camo real.
Hey, and forget
the salt water.
We're gonna put the sharks
in muddy water.
(laughter, duck call quacks)
(laughter)
So, boys, are you basically
photographing a terrain,
and then taking that image
and putting it onto cloth?
Is that what's really
going on here?
Basically, that's the way
we do it.
It's about a 54-Step process,
believe it or not.
Would anybody like a hat?
(Lori) Yes.
(Robert) Oh, of course.
Sure, if it's free.
Thank you.
Sure.
Here's a hat, Daymond.
Thank you.
Sure.
Let's go back
to why you're doing this.
Let's assume a fact here.
Okay.
Ducks are birds.
Right.
They got bird brains.
(laughs)
They fly over hunters
every day.
They get blasted out of the sky.
That happens every day.
Now are you saying
to me as an investor,
"I can blast more ducks."
Right.
"20% more ducks die
because of this technology"?
it's gonna hide you better.
Are you selling the technology
to camo companies,
or are you actually
selling your own garments
with your camo on it?
We are selling both.
Okay.
What are your sales,
Steven, so far?
So far this year,
they're $150,000.
Your sales, total?
Our--Our sales total
This year.
Now, it--This is
a seasonal business,
and we have not made it
to our first season yet.
So I tell you,
you've done a very good job
of camouflaging your valuation.
Well...
(Lori laughs)
in fact, you've done such
a good job of camouflaging it,
Kevin didn't pick up on it.
They're not worth $3 million?
Oh, you did catch that.
I hadn't got
to that yet.
How did you get
to the $3 million?
We have to look at
the size of the market.
(Kevin) Yep.
Try to figure out
how--How much of it--
Never heard that before.
How much of it
we can capture.
Okay.
We had to produce our products
and get to the market.
How much money
have you put in so far
to produce the product
and get to where you are?
Uh, there's $600,000
invested in the product.
Whoa.
And where'd you get that?
Your money?
We have already raised money
with other investors.
Oh...
and what value
did they put on the company?
They put $2 1/2 million
on the business
before we sold anything.
Come on.
(Stephen)
We didn't have clothing.
All we had was
a piece of material.
Now these people
are hunters, now,
they've been hunting
their whole life,
and they look
at what we have...
really?
Yes.
This is unbelievable.
♪♪♪
We have already raised money
with other investors.
What value
did they put on the company?
They put $2 1/2 million
on the business...
really?
Before we sold anything.
This is unbelievable.
You have the same brain
as a duck
if you think I'm gonna give you
a $3 million valuation on this.
$3 million's a joke.
Be nice.
You sold what percentage
of the company?
16%.
Okay, so you sold
16% of the company.
So when you sat down
and you talked to 'em
and you said, "suckers..."
I mean, "investors..."
(Steve laughs)
No, seriously,
you said, "guys,
"here's how big
we think we can be
within 'x' number of years."
What did you tell them?
We think we could take our sales
within the first three years
to $3 million.
Where are you selling
right now?
We have 58 different
retail stores
around the country right now
that are selling our products.
Are you in any
of the big boys--
Dick's, gander mountain...
Bass pro?
Bass pro shops?
We are not,
and one of the reasons is
we knew we were brand-New,
and if we'd have knocked
on Dick's
or cabela's or whatever's door,
they wouldn't have known
who we are,
and they're gonna
license proven products.
If you compare what we have
to what's on the market,
it is
an absolute no-brainer.
I get that it's different.
Okay.
Right? I get that it's,
you know, more innovative.
Sure.
But that
doesn't necessarily mean
people are going to buy it.
You have to be telling me
that you're gonna get bubba
and what bubba typically wears
and put them out of business,
and own 100% of the market.
We don't have to own
100% of the market
to get to a value
of $3 million.
But you've gotta be
changing the game.
Not even close.
You've gotta
change the game.
Waterfowl hunters
spend $400 million on gear
a year, okay?
So I can get $3 million
without putting anybody
out of business.
Look, I'm not a duck Hunter.
I don't have to know your
business to be a good investor.
But, man...
a $3 million valuation?
For a pattern that looks
a little different in my eye?
Definitely not
the right investor. I'm out.
Thank you.
You will sell this.
This is a great idea.
But you came in
asking for too much.
I'm out.
You are out of
your minds.
(Stephen and Steve laugh)
$3 million dollars
is, you know, that price...
(Mark) But $2.5 million isn't.
(quacks)
Exactly. That's where
that price is.
Shucky ducky quack quack.
I'm out.
I think the biggest risk,
actually,
is not the quality
or the success
or the opportunity.
It's that
you've got 16 investors.
I'm gonna be a pimple
on a duck's Butt at 5%.
(Stephen and Steve laugh)
It's just not worth it.
Big pimple.
I'm out.
You know, I'm not interested
in your retail strategy.
I'm interested
in your licensing strategy.
I am the king
of licensing strategies.
If you want to become
the standard,
as mark said earlier,
change the game...
you're exactly right.
You've gotta grow very quickly,
and you've gotta get
the top three guys
to license this from you,
and that's where I am gonna
come in really handy.
I'll give you $150,000
for 20%. Very fair.
(laughs)
Very reasonable.
And let's go
kill some ducks.
We're not gonna take
a valuation
that's lower
than what we already have.
Do you have a counteroffer?
Uh, you probably don't even
wanna hear it.
I'm out.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks, guys.
Congratulations.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
(Lori) Bye. Good luck.
All right.
Hey, sharks,
you're bird-brains for not
investing in this company.
(quacking)
♪♪♪
In season 3, Pat Mccarthy
Turned down an offer
from Daymond John
for his fragrance company,
liquid money.
I can't do 80%.
Then I'm out.
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪♪
Walking away from Daymond
was one of
the most difficult decisions
I've had to make.
Good evening.
But the advice that I got
was absolutely priceless.
Shortly after
I appeared on "Shark Tank,"
the Venetian called,
and they gave us
the largest order
we've ever received.
(pop, cheering)
Yeah! (laughs)
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had roughly $200,000
in sales.
Here's to money.
To money!
After "Shark Tank,"
sales ballooned to almost
a million dollars
in nine months.
(hisses)
I never envisioned
making this much money.
We've hired
six full-time people.
Our plant is running
at full capacity.
We are making a ton of money.
Being on "Shark Tank"
has opened up doors
that I never would have
been able to open.
The dream has now
become reality.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
are Megan Jackson Carreker
and Aimee Miller,
with a favorable staple
in women's fashion.
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks.
I'm Megan Jackson Carreker.
And I'm Aimee Miller.
We're Texas girls.
Our company's hip chixs,
and we're seeking $150,000
for 35% equity in our company.
Hip chixs is a fun
and sexy premium denim line,
and we think that this is
the best butt
that money can buy.
Megan and I
were sorority sisters
and best friends
at Baylor university.
Aw.
We're completely
obsessed with denim.
I mean, you wouldn't catch me
on a day not wearing jeans.
I even own 75 pairs.
Whoa.
But who could blame her?
Jeans are the ultimate
American fashion staple.
And we couldn't
find a perfect pair
to fit every occasion.
You know,
day and night...
Dressy, casual...
that was comfortable,
breathable, sexy and slimming.
So we set out
to create the perfect pair.
Hip chixs is highlighting
the sexiness
of a woman's natural body
with our angled pocket
and our curved yoke--
Are gonna help your backside
look more trim.
And no more muffin top.
(Megan and Amy laugh)
Aah...
you don't want that.
I guess Mark's out.
Oh! I am muffin-Top-Free,
I'll tell you.
We also have a specialized
waistband in the back
which is gonna keep it
from riding down
when you bend over,
so not to reveal
the dreaded whale tail.
(Robert) don't!
(laughter)
I've never heard that before.
You call that a whale toe?
A whale tail.
Whale tail.
We see hip chixs becoming
the next hottest,
sought-after
premium denim lines
that every woman
will want in her closet.
We're at our tipping point.
Hip chixs needs your help
to really scale us
to that national level.
And like we love
to say in Texas...
(together)
Y'all want some of this.
(Daymond laughs)
(laughs)
Are you wearing them?
Yes.
Because I just want to see
why your jeans stop whale tail
and muffin top.
Why is this different?
Just because it stretches?
No, because usually,
waistbands are, like,
more of a circular,
and ours is kind of an angle,
so we have a little bit
more length back here,
so that when you do bend down,
it's not gonna show everything.
And then muffin top--
What if--What if
you have a couple rolls?
It's a really forgiving fabric.
It's really slimming.
Do you have any sales?
We do. We have
$12,000 worth of sales.
Oh.
Megan, there's gotta be a story.
Why only $12,000?
Why are you here?
Well, we--We originally
created a test.
We did two years of research.
Basically, we wanted
to meet the need in the market.
So we met with boutiques
and said, "what's selling,
and what are you lacking?"
and we designed for that,
and we created
a premium product, meaning...
in 1 year, $12,000.
Yes. Yes.
In 1 year, $12,000.
Off of 300 pairs.
So once Kevin gives you
the $150,000,
tell me what the next
12 months are gonna look like.
What we wanna do with the money
is drive sales.
So we've got
to build a sales force.
We have to develop
more product.
We only created two styles,
so we need more styles.
I don't wanna discount
the $12,000.
But if you got the investment,
what would the sales be
and how would you get them?
So over the next 12 months,
we're hoping to be
around $850,000 revenue.
And how are you gonna do that?
Through boutiques.
So, I mean,
we'd love to do more P.R.,
marketing.
The exposure we've had
so far in the last year,
we haven't spent
one dime on it.
How did those
300 units selling
compare to other jeans?
So at--at this boutique,
they've got over
30 brands of jeans,
and we were within
their top 25% Sellers.
How much do these jeans
retail for?
$187.
And how much do you
sell it to the store for?
Wow.
We sell for $80.
And how much
do you make it for?
$68.
It's $68.
$68, and you sell it
for $80?
Mm-hmm.
Because--
You are going to hell.
Well, we...
exactly.
We add the premium charge.
We wanted to flip
our profit margin
by ordering bigger.
You're making no money.
That's--That's why
we're here.
That's--Yeah.
We want to place
a bigger order, so...
so the cost...
I have to go
to hell with you?
That's why you're here?
No, you're gonna go
on This great journey with us.
It'll be so much fun.
We're gonna paint the town red.
This is my space,
and most of the jean players
are trying to bring
their jean price down to $120.
Because the days
of $180, $220...
it's--It's really over.
Right now people can't pay
their mortgages.
They're--they're wearing
that favorite pair of jeans
forever now.
Daymond, if I came to you,
and I said,
"Let's launch a denim brand.
"Let's hire a designer,
and I want to fund it.
Here's a check."
You tell me what that check
has to be for
for me to get 1% market share
in the next 5 years.
To launch a denim line?
$5 million.
I'm in.
(laughter)
You didn't ask
for enough money!
That's the problem!
That's it! I knew it.
(laughs)
Look, you're--You're
incredibly nice people.
You've done a great job
with your presentation.
What?!
I just don't think
one store is enough.
I'm out today.
Okay.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
I think that you need
a lot of money,
and I think it's really
too high a hill to tackle.
But you're a designer.
Design something else.
Do something
unique and different,
where you don't have
a lot of competition.
And then have something where
you're cornering the market,
and people will back you,
and you can
get out there quickly.
So that's my recommendation.
And I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
If I were you, I would take
100, 200 pair of jeans,
and because women
are obsessed with the fit,
every single female star
in the world
thinks they can be
a designer tomorrow,
and they know nothing about it.
You mail 200 pair of those
out to each individual person,
and you tell them you want
to partner up with one of them,
believe it or not,
one of them may say,
"This is such
an incredible pair.
Yes, I'll partner up
with you."
And then you take that
to a... a shark,
and they will die
to give you the money.
It's just that simple.
Hmm.
But today...
I'm out.
That hurt.
So anybody else?
If you can make
a woman's tushie
look significantly better
than anybody else's,
you're gonna be able
to build a following of people
who will pay a premium, who are
waiting for your next product.
It's gonna take longer,
it's gonna be slower,
the margins won't be
as--As strong,
but you can get there.
I'm not the right person
to help you.
But I'm telling you,
do not quit.
It's not about spending
$5 million.
It's just about
grinding it out and doing it.
So I wish you guys
nothing but the best.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Mark is doing you
a huge disservice.
No.
Let me speak, Mark.
Your probability of success
in this market is zero.
So the more time you spend
pursuing this dream,
the more you'll be wasting
your precious time.
If you're truly entrepreneurs,
go find something where
the probability of success
is more than zero.
No chance that you will get
share in the Jean business.
I'm out.
(Robert)
Megan, Aimee, thank you.
Good luck.
(sighs)
Man, you gotta
learn to be...
are you guys kidding?
You gotta learn
to be nicer to people.
What?!
why crush their dreams?
I mean, give...
because it's--It's not
a dream, it's a nightmare, Lori.
It's--
You're mean
and nasty, Kevin.
It's the truth.
Anything else
under the Hood?
It's the truth.
Thank goodness I'm here.
I'm proud of what we've done.
300 pairs to develop
and sell is amazing.
We have--We have something.
Nobody goes out
and buys something
they've never heard of for $200
because it isn't great.
It is great.
♪♪♪
(birds chirping)
(bell clangs)
♪♪♪
I'm Brooks...
I'm Taylor...
and I'm Tanner.
We're brothers
from Boise, Idaho,
and we're the owners of Proof.
(beeping)
Hey, dad. What's going on?
Hi, guys.
Got a load
of, uh, ponderosa pine
from central Oregon.
(Taylor) 60 years ago, our
grandfather started Woodgrain,
a wood products
manufacturing company
that's still in our family today
and run by our dad.
So we decided to incorporate
a family tradition
and start Proof--
The next generation
in our family business.
(buzzing)
Our product's made from wood,
which makes it
completely unique.
So we can guarantee
our customer
that they have a one-of-a-kind,
handmade original.
(Brooks)
We're really excited
to introduce our product
to America.
We think that
it's really gonna change
the way that people
look at wood.
We need an investment
from the sharks
because proof
is growing so fast.
We need the capital
to invest in inventory
to keep up with
the demand of our customers.
We have a lot
riding on this deal.
Proof is a family company
that we hope to pass on
to our children one day.
So this means
the world to us.
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks. I'm Brooks...
I'm Tanner...
and I'm Taylor,
and we're the Dame brothers
from Boise, Idaho.
Our company is Proof eyewear.
We are seeking an investment
of $150,000
for a 10% share
in our innovative company.
At Proof,
we create the most amazing
one-of-a-kind
handcrafted eyewear
from the most sustainable
woods available.
As we have grown, we have added
other eco-friendly frames
from materials such as
plant-based plastics
and recycled
skateboard decks.
I started Proof in my garage
a little over a year ago.
As Proof started getting
more and more popular
and started showing up
on famous people's faces
and in International
publications around the world,
it became more than I could
handle by myself,
and I needed some help
in a major way,
so I brought these two guys in
to help me out.
For me, really,
it was a no-brainer,
because, "a,"
I can trust them,
I knew their work ethic.
Heck, I used to give these guys
wedgies when they were little.
(laughter)
And, "B," you know,
they work for cheap.
So that's a win-win, right?
In addition to that,
our family's been
in the wood business
for a real long time.
We like to joke that we have
sawdust in our veins.
We bought each shark
their own personalized pair
of proofs they can check out.
We even engraved
with your names in 'em.
Thank you.
Kevin, they've got,
uh, spring hinges,
so they'll even fit
big heads like yours.
(Robert) Let me see, Kevin.
Let's see.
(laughs)
You look ridiculous.
We got him
some green lenses, too.
The color of money.
Daymond, let me see yours.
Let's see.
Oh, yours are cool.
Mark, you look ridiculous.
(laughs)
He's ready
for a night on the town.
You guys are looking stylish.
That's all I can say
right now.
Please note the uniqueness
of the wood grain.
No two trees
are exactly alike, right?
Making no two pairs of Proofs
exactly alike.
This makes your pair
a one-of-a-kind,
handmade original.
Over six decades ago,
our grandfather
took his small Wood sawmill
from a one-man show
to becoming
a very successful business.
With his example
of hard work,
dedication, and creativity,
we're prepared
to take proof
from three brothers
from Idaho
to becoming a major success
in the eyewear industry.
Entrepreneurs like us
don't grow on trees...
(Robert laughs)
Even though the majority
of our products do.
Speaking of things
that grow on trees,
we need your money
to make this dream come true.
Sharks, who's gonna become
part of the Proof family?
Do you have any sales?
Yeah, we've sold a little bit.
Uh, in the last 12 months,
we've had $433,000
worth of sales.
Whoa.
Wow, that's good.
Yeah, not bad.
You don't seem proud of that.
We're very proud of that.
You know, it's, uh, it's...
but you're kind of, like,
"Oh, Gee, shucks..."
we gotta be humble.
We're from humble beginnings.
We're from Idaho.
We're humble boys.
But we work hard.
You should be proud of that.
How did you sell that?
$433,000--
Grassroots marketing.
Uh, we've gone to trade shows.
And, uh, it really comes down to
the product really sells itself.
What does it cost
to manufacture
the case, the glasses,
the lens?
What is your--your cost?
The cost with the packaging
and the sunglasses is $14.
What do you sell it
to a retailer for?
Around $50 wholesale,
and $100 retail.
What celebrities and what
magazines did you get in?
That's a great question.
It's a good question.
We've been on, uh,
Snoop Dogg's face,
Beyonce, Kelly Rowland...
Shannon Brown.
And they endorsed them?
We've gotten tweets--
We don't send the product out
and say, like, "Hey, will you
wear these and endorse us?"
you just saw them
wearing them?
It just happens.
We've had a budget of zero
for our marketing,
but we hustle a lot.
Wood is extremely hot
right now.
Crazy.
You're absolutely right.
Everybody's doing chains,
they're doing watches.
So you guys
are the official "Wood guys"?
right?
We're the woodies, you know?
We're the wood brothers.
There are other wood sunglasses.
I've seen them, right?
Oh. Plenty, yeah.
What we've really
strived to do
is really build a brand
around the product.
Tanner, tell me about the logo.
What's the significance?
How'd you come up with that?
Really, when we started proof,
we actually wanted to give back
in what we did,
and so we're working on building
an eye clinic in India.
And so part of our sales
that we have,
we--we donate
to this eye clinic in India.
For us, the idea
behind the bird logo
is everybody
has wings to fly.
Sometimes they just need
a little help...
Oh.
To catch flight.
It's a great story.
It's nice.
$433,000 last year.
What do you think
your sales will be this year?
I think we're gonna do about
$850,000 to $900,000 in sales.
On the $433,000
that we've sold,
$150,000 is profit.
What we're doing, really,
is putting a lot of the money
back into inventory.
I mean, I'm not
taking a salary,
and these two guys
are working--
I mean,
they could make more money
working at Mcdonald's, really.
Is this your only job?
I have a full-Time job.
I work in
our family's business,
in the wood business
full-Time.
You know, I've sold millions
of dollars of glasses.
I don't know if you--if you're
aware of that or not.
We're big fans, yeah.
And I'm partners with a large
company that makes sunglasses.
And I'm afraid it's going
to be a conflict for me
with that partnership.
And as much
as I love you guys,
I'm gonna have to be out.
Okay.
Thanks, Lori.
What are you here looking for
to get to that next
jump-off point?
What we're really looking for
is money for inventory.
We actually have
a small problem--
I don't know if it's a problem.
It's an opportunity--
Where one of
our biggest retailers
has come to us,
and they wanna expand with us.
We've gotta get
our inventory on point.
Who's the retailer,
and what's the order?
Pacific Sunwear.
Yeah, exactly.
Is the--
we initially started,
um, in five stores.
And within two weeks,
they got back to us,
and said, "Hey,
we're gonna do ten."
and then they just recently
got to us last week
and said, "Hey, we need
to open--Open 50 stores
for the holiday season."
And that equates
to an order of over $200,000.
Wow.
Yeah, but, guys, when
you're turning your sales
at a relatively slow rate,
you can slow down
your customers,
which you've been able to do.
But once it starts to sell,
and there's other people
knocking on the door,
and they're saying, "guys,
if you can't hit this order
"for 150 pairs
for a thousand stores.
I gotta take it
somewhere else"...
you got a problem.
What are you gonna do?
Maybe the answer to that is
structuring a deal
with one of you
where you say, "Okay,
you have--You have access
to more capital if needed."
So what you're saying is,
"come on, guys.
Give us more."
And free sunglasses for life.
Free sunglasses for life.
And sunglasses for life?
Yeah, but they're not
saying that, mark.
You're saying that.
I love the sunglasses,
but I'm out.
Thanks, mark.
If you went to general retail,
like a Costco,
does that kill the brand today?
I-I would say so.
I mean, at the beginning,
we didn't wanna grow super fast.
(Daymond) The good news is
that in a down economy,
where apparel
and everything is horrible...
Yeah.
Oh, for sure.
You guys are actually getting
interest from Pacsun, right?
Right.
So that's great.
You're cool.
Thank you.
I've had a lot
of cool companies.
Heatherette was
my most famous company
that I've owned
that was really, really cool.
But the problem is--was all
the cool brands are broke.
Most people would say,
"I don't wanna ever
be in Walmart."
I'm dying to be in Walmart.
Um, so we wouldn't have
the same vision.
I wish you luck.
I'm out.
Thanks, Daymond.
Wow. The cool, hip...
Cool is not hip.
I thought you'd be
all over this.
Cool and a profit
are two different things.
I'm already cool and hip.
That's true.
(laughter)
Well, here's something
I'll throw out at you--
I'll give you the $150,000
for 25%.
I want $2.50 per order...
Hell, no!
Until I get my capital back.
And then it drops to a dollar.
Mr. Wonderful
is also the undertaker.
I don't want
to fund inventory with equity.
I want my equity because
I'm getting involved
in a business I'm gonna
be with for a few years.
That way, I get a constant,
you know, return of my capital.
I'm a quarter-Partner
with you guys,
and I've funded the business.
All right,
so there's an offer--
You get
the $150,000 today,
that's gonna fill one order.
When you wake up tomorrow,
what's the plan then?
You gotta be very careful
about taking
anything off the top
of your gross,
and then paying it out
to somebody at this point.
What is this,
"advice tank?"
(laughter)
Or are you gonna
make 'em an offer?
So I'll give you
the $150,000 for 25%.
No royalty,
because that's ridiculous
at this point in your company.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Kevin and Robert have each
offered the Dame brothers
$150,000 for 25%
of their company.
However, Kevin also
wants a royalty
on each pair of glasses sold.
Well, guys, you got
two offers on the table.
Gotta make
a decision, guys.
Yeah.
And you have sharks
fighting for you.
Let me reiterate
the offers--
Let me--so it's $150,000
for 25% from me.
I'll give you
$150,000 for 25%.
Robert's deal--
That's it.
Mine--
I get $2.50 per order
until my capital
is returned,
then it drops to a dollar.
How is your order
better than Robert's?
It's always better
when you have me.
Difference
between Mr. O'Leary and I--
I don't shuffle money around
on wall street
and take a few bucks.
I built a $100 million business
in record time.
Mr. Wonderful knows
the life cycle of cash.
We don't know what's gonna
happen to this thing.
In my structure,
I get my capital back
in about 14 months.
I'm happy with that.
After that, I drop out...
Look, guys, I'm not--I'm not
really worried
about getting
my capital back today.
Well, I always worry
about my capital.
I think a real investor
worries about
growing the company.
I know if you grow
the company,
and we have
a successful company,
we'll all get our money back.
To--to put in
an investment at this point,
and your primary reason
and worry is,
"how do I get my few Pennies
back along the way?"
I mean, that's ridiculous.
It's--That's ridiculous, too.
You know, let me
tell you something...
(laughs)
You guys should be taking some
off the table every month,
because you don't know
what's gonna happen.
That's ridiculous!
Why would you--
He doesn't understand
the cycle of cash.
Look, I-I know
how to scale a business.
I know how to grow it quickly.
The more successful
you are,
the more capital
you're gonna need.
That's the challenge
of inventory-Based growth.
Anyways, I've made you
an offer.
What do you think
about it?
We appreciate the offers,
and...
Let us--Let us make
a phone call.
All right.
And, uh...
(Taylor) We'll be back.
We'll regroup here a second.
Thanks.
(whistling)
I really like them.
They're gonna be
too cool for school.
This is
a ride-the-wave business.
Hey, pops. How we doing?
Hey, Brooks, how are ya?
Good I'm here
with Tanner and Taylor,
and, uh, we've got
two offers on the table
that we wanted to get--
Get your opinion on.
Ah, great. Congratulations.
Thanks.
I think they're on to something.
I think this is a hot wave.
You ride it for a while,
and you hope you figure it out.
I would never do this deal
without my capital
being returned, ever.
Boy, what are
they gonna do?
The advantage of taking on
a partner
is the additional
working capital is good...
Mm-hmm.
And the expertise is good.
Obviously, the downside
is you dilute your ownership.
Appreciate it, pops.
Love ya.
We love you. Bye-Bye.
See ya.
All right, let's go.
Well, we talked
to the old man.
You know, he gave us
some good advice.
Would either of you guys
be willing to--
to up--up the amount?
'cause, I mean, you're basically
valuating our company
at $600,000.
We got $433,000
of sales today.
I think our company's worth
more than $600,000.
Now you're getting smart.
(Robert) Hallelujah.
Our grandpa
started with nothing.
I mean, the guy
used to be a truck driver.
He would mold wood,
and then take it to California
on the weekend,
and then flip back around
and mold wood all week,
and then take it back down.
So he's just a hustler.
He's about
building the business.
Our dad is the C.E.O.
of the company today,
and our--Our family
is about building business
and supporting people.
I mean, our family business,
we have...
(voice breaking) 17...
1,700 people
that... (laughs)
1,700 people that we support.
And so, you know, we started
out with three people,
and we have seven people
in our business,
and we wanna...
man, I don't know.
We're about making, uh,
making this thing go.
And we wanna build it
with a good partner
that supports us and wants to
see this thing be successful.
Make a counteroffer.
That's why
it's called a "Shark Tank."
Uh, Robert, would you
be willing to, uh,
go to $200,000
for 20% equity in the company?
I think that's
a fair valuation of our--
of our company at this point.
So you want him
to up his cash
and reduce his ask?
Correct.
And we'd also like
to kind of understand
if you'd be willing
to help us going forward
getting financing
if--If necessary.
Well, uh, you've asked
for two concessions from me--
more cash, less equity.
Of course I'm gonna
help you find the funding.
Of course I'm gonna help you
with advice.
I'm gonna stick
to the $150,000 and 25%.
Okay.
What do you guys think?
♪♪♪
I think--I think we're gonna
have to pass on the offer.
Ooh.
(Kevin) Oh.
All right.
You know, I was about
to get up and say,
"This is great.
We're gonna build something."
I wish we were doing that.
'cause we see that you
have a lot of passion
for what you do,
and--And really appreciate
the offer,
and, honestly,
flattered and honored
to--to be with you guys.
Are you sure?
(chuckles)
We are. We are sure.
Guys, you let greed
cloud your vision.
Enjoy the shades.
We appreciate it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
(Lori) Good luck.
Well, guys...
(exhales and groans)
Could have helped
those guys.
No deal for either of us.
That's a tragedy.
You know what I say now?
Robert, they saved you
from years of problems
with the cool-guy syndrome.
I really wanted
to work with those guys.
I think we could have
built something great.
We believe in building brands.
It's not about--
Always about the money.
It's not always
about doing the deal
and having that partner with--
You know, that's--That's flashy.
It's about staying true
to who you are
and doing a deal
that makes sense.